cómo podría funcionar esta idea de un
club europeo que no necesariamente
implique la adhesión de más países a la
unión europea
es una idea interesante es una idea aún
difusa no parece que se trata no
necesariamente siempre de una
simplemente de una continuación de la
política de vecindad pero posiblemente
de un club de una comunidad política que
tenga en cuenta intereses en el sector
de seguridad en el sector energético que
podría entonces expandir ciertas
políticas que son de gran interés para
los para los países del oriente del
continente europeo
no miembros de la unión europea eso
sería una idea interesante
pero todavía no sabemos varios factores
que podrían impactar su viabilidad no
sabemos si países como ucrania
ucrania en este momento está
sacrificando
de manera increíble para también para la
seguridad del occidente no sabemos si
realmente después de aún una solución
del conflicto
contemporáneo si realmente va a aceptar
una posición que podría percibirse como
periferia
ahora podría rusia ver este proyecto
como una amenaza en medio del apoyo
occidental que ha recibido ucrania desde
el inicio de la guerra
creo que debemos despedirnos de la idea
que rusia reacciona a acciones
exteriores a rusia
hemos observado que varias veces rusia
cometió actos de agresión contra ucrania
incluso esta invasión esta guerra de
aniquilación que estamos observando sin
provocación cualquiera y en ese sentido
podemos decir cualquier cosa que pasa
fuera de rusia puede servir para
cualquier tipo de
legitimación del discurso de narrativa
por parte de putin pero en realidad no
creo que va que va a haber
necesariamente una relación causal con
alguna nueva estrategia rusa en este
momento de todas formas el poderío
militar denuncia poco a poco se está
acabando en oriente de ucrania así que
aún nuestro seguro qué tipo de medida va
a querer tomar
bueno y por otro lado cuál es la
importancia de que el primer viaje
internacional del segundo mandato de
macrón sea en alemania y no en otro país
de europa
eso ya es casi una tradición no
tradicionalmente alemania y francia se
han percibido como motor de la unión
europea aunque en estos momentos no
puede dudar si realmente ese motor va a
mantener su relevancia si realmente van
a hacer alemania y francia- que van a
continuar impulsando la dinámica de la
integración europea porque en este
momento en realidad las preocupaciones
que predominan en el escenario político
europeo son preocupaciones de seguridad
en oriente y en realidad han sido los
países de
europa central como polonia república
checa eslovaquia
que han dado las respuestas más
significativas en términos de apoyo de
armamentos a ucrania y en esa situación
seguramente va a ser muy importante para
los dos países
y encontrar nuevas estrategias en común
para mantener su relevancia y para
encontrar nuevos puntos en común con
europa central y con nuevos socios como
obviamente ucrania